okay you guys are freaking amazing um
what are your thoughts on the overall
season how are you feeling what's going
through your head right now
i have learned so much this season i've
gained so much this season
and i've won so much this season i mean
the mirror ball obviously is what
everybody was here for
but i walked in knowing that i was here
for the mirror ball but i walked out
realizing that the mirror was not the
only thing that i needed it's only
something that i wanted but there was a
lot that i won here that i needed and it
feels so good to
have those in my heart now yeah
are you gonna be at cardi b's for
christmas like i really want to know
this
honestly i mean if i'm there for
christmas great but i told cardi i was
like we had a little talk backstage
after and i told her i was like i'm down
to me culture i'm down to hang out
i'm not gonna charge you anything i
don't know where you got that from i
will just hang out with you
uh but i don't wanna i don't wanna like
crash your family christmas so i'll be
there whenever you want
what are your thoughts on iman winning
iman is
like a brother he has for some reason i
feel like we got closest to iman and
olivia and iman has just always treated
us like sisters little sisters and so to
see him win was
amazing incredible yeah you guys just
honestly you inspired so many people if
not for nothing you inspired so many
people you inspired me so many different
people all over the world commenting on
your performances and your friendship
what is that going to look like after
the show like is this
an everyday thing are you going to be
able to see each other often still
absolutely um this this is a forever
kind of thing i'm
so grateful that she popped into my life
i don't know what my life looked like
before her so it's really wild um but
i'm so grateful for these past three
months yeah and jojo lastly just your
evolution we really did watch you mature
and grow on the show how does that feel
for you
it's wild it's wild that
i trusted one person
and it was the best thing that i ever
did for myself personally it's
jenna gave me the little like flick that
i needed yeah and it's something that
i'm forever grateful for
having this evolution is something that
i didn't know was gonna happen and i
didn't know when or how or what but it
did naturally and it's just been amazing
that's awesome thank you for your time
thank you
you